[Musique]
pendant que les shadoks et les antis
shadoks régler leur histoire
la fusée des jib y est parti ça s'était
passé un matin sans difficulté
[Musique]
et les jib y découvrir l'espace avec ces
planètes et ses paysages
en ce temps là il n'y avait pas mal de
choses à voir dans l'espace
et comme il n'était pas très pressé il
avait décidé de faire un peu de tourisme
cosmique
[Musique]
quand il trouvait un endroit qui leur
plaisait s'arrêter pour pique-niquer ou
bien nous ouvraient leurs fusées et
donner des représentations
il faisait ça uniquement pour s'amuser
car le plus souvent il n'y avait
personne pour les regarder mais
quelquefois si caen mais il y avait les
poissons de la planète à poisson par
exemple qui grimpaient dans leur arbre
pour les regarde
il faut savoir qu'on ce temps là les
poissons avait des petites pattes et se
promenait dans les arbres aussi
facilement que vous et moi les jbe les
avait fait tellement rire qu'ils en
avaient versé des taux en larmes
et quand l'egypte y avait dû partir il
en avait versé d'autres encore si bien
que les arbres avaient été obligés et de
nager et c'est depuis ce temps là que
les arbres nage et les poissons aussi
d'ailleurs
[Musique]